okay so
the aclu used to be
uh an organization that would defend i
mean they had they have civil liberties
right in their name
and they used to defend free speech
that's what that's what they did
and we talked about this before i mean
how
there there was a time when the aclu
was so
militant in their defense of free speech
that they would defend uh
kkk members they would defend
not mean actual nazis okay they would
defend actual neo-nazis
um
and defend their free speech
those times are long gone
because there's a case uh in loudoun
county i mean loudoun county has become
the kind of epicenter of many of these
battles in the school system with
critical race theory and with gender
theory
so as you've heard from me on this show
um part of that that policy in loudoun
county where they're opening up the
bathrooms
um to to allow boys into girls bathrooms
even though
a girl was allegedly raped inside of a
bathroom by a boy
uh only just last semester in may
but this is a policy that doesn't just
affect bathrooms and sports teams
also very significantly it requires
teachers to use the preferred pronouns
of um
to use the preferred pronouns of
whatever you know of the students
whatever they say their pronoun is the
teachers have to use it so this is
compelled speech
and it's not just compelling compelled
speech is
bad in and of itself
but what are they being what is the
compelled speech
what are they being compelled to affirm
they're being compelled to affirm a
falsehood
as a condition of further employment
and not further employment in the
private sector but
in the school
run by the government
so to have a
job in this government building
you have to be willing to affirm
falsehoods
a boy says refer to me as a girl that is
a
confirmed absolute falsehood and the
policy says you have to affirm it or
you're gone
so this is this case is making its way
um through the court system
and now we have this from the aclu of
virginia
it says breaking three teachers in
loudoun county are going to court simply
because they don't want to use trans and
non-non-binary students pronouns we and
partners filed an amicus brief to tell
the court
refusing to use a student's pronouns
because of who they are is
discrimination and then they have their
amicus amicus brief
um
so they're getting out of going out of
their way to involve themselves in this
case
to be on the side of compelling people
to say things
this isn't this is no matter how else
you feel about it
this is without a question an anti-free
speech perspective
even if you think that
you should use the preferred pronouns
that someone
asks you to use or demands that you use
normally
and if that's your position
[Music]
you can't pretend if you're trying to
force people to do that you can't
pretend that you're on the side of free
speech you're not this is this is
compelled speech
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated